SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY:
Good afternoon.
My name is Sridhar
Ramaswamy, I'm
the SVP for ads and
payments at Google.
As you saw in [? Sundar's ?]
keynote in the morning,
the Android platform
has tremendous momentum.
And today I'm very
pleased to tell you
about the next
generation of payments
that we are going to
be doing on Android.
Of course, it's 3:00
in the afternoon,
and we wanted to perk you
guys up to start with,
so we thought we would start
by showing a funny picture
of cute babies or cute cats.
We did a lot of research
and went with cute babies.
But we realized we could
also use this picture
to make a really
important point, which
is last year four times as
many Android devices were sold
every day as were babies born.
Our activation
numbers are something
like a million and a
half devices activated
every single day.
That's, like, some babies
with a lot of phones.
And what's also amazing
about the rise of smartphones
in general is the
tremendous engagement
that consumers have
with these devices.
The average consumer takes their
phones out 150 times a day.
That's close to 10
for every waking hour.
And these devices, which
not so long ago were just
simple things for
making phone calls,
have almost become
extensions of ourselves.
Close to 2/3 of us
sleep with our phones
right next to our bed.
It's the first thing
I touch every morning
to turn off my alarm.
And through the day we use our
phones for texting our loved
ones, looking up directions,
checking up on traffic,
seeing what the weather's like,
being amused and entertained,
buying stuff online,
the list goes on and on.
And in fact, we are all more
likely to check to make sure
that we have our
phones in our pockets
when we leave our home
than we are to check
for our wallet or our keys.
That's pretty amazing.
But there is one thing that
we do not yet commonly do
as consumers, and that is
pay for physical purchases
with our phones.
Four years ago, we
pioneered a technology
to store payment
credentials securely
on the phone using a
technology called Near Field
Communication, or NFC.
We also pioneered a scheme by
which these credentials could
be securely transmitted to
merchant point of sale devices
to complete the payment.
We called the
scheme tap and pay.
And we are excited
today because we
think the overall
ecosystem is at a point
that these payments can
achieve massive scale.
Why do we say that?
We think the current world is
ready, both at a consumer level
and at a merchant level,
and these are two really,
really important prerequisites
for any large scale
change to happen in a
complicated and important world
like payments.
To start with, on
the consumer side,
seven out of ten Android
devices in use today
are already capable of
making NFC payments.
These are phones that
are out there today,
being used by people.
And pretty much every
new Android device
that ships is also
capable of NFC payments.
And this means
that consumers can
go buy new Android phones
knowing that mobile payments
just is there.
They come along for the ride.
And then on the
merchant side, there
are over 700,000
merchant locations
that can accept tap
and pay payments.
And in fact, here's an amazing
little map of all the locations
where people are using Android
phones to tap and pay today.
And further, the merchant
ecosystem in the US
is in the midst of an
upgrade cycle with respect
to all of their point
of sale devices.
That is going to provide
better security for all of us
as consumers, but
also these devices
will be capable of
accepting NFC payments.
We really think that it is the
confluence of a huge number
of devices-- consumer
devices-- in use,
new ones that are coming out
being capable of making NFC
payments, and the
fact that there
is going to be a tremendous
upsurge in the number
of merchant terminals that
can accept NFC payments that
makes this a right moment
for big changes to happen.
So we've been working to
create support for payments
at a core platform
level in Android.
And as you heard earlier,
we call this Android Pay.
So Android Pay will be built
deep within the Android
ecosystem, and it
is going to serve
as the glue between
consumers and merchants.
And we had a few core principles
that we adopted for Android
Pay, and those were simplicity.
It should be really easy
for all consumers to use.
It should be secure.
There's a lot of doubt
and worry that we
have about the constant
stream of breaking news
that we all keep hearing.
And there should be
choice for consumers,
in terms of the devices that
they use, in terms of the apps
that they could use in order
to make these payments.
And Android Pay is
going to be the solution
both for physical payments at
stores but also for payments
within the apps that we all
have on our Android phones.
So it's going to solve the
problem of mobile payments
in a pretty comprehensive way.
I'm very pleased to
welcome Ariel Bardin, who
is the Product Vice President
for Payments at Google,
and Pali Bhat, the Director of
Consumer Payments at Google,
to tell us a lot more
about Android Pay.
Ariel, Pali?
[APPLAUSE]
ARIEL BARDIN:
Thank you, Sridhar.
PALI BHAT: Thanks, Sridhar.
ARIEL BARDIN: Thank you.
So we're very excited
to be here today
to share some more
information about Android Pay.
We're going to have some fun.
Pali's going to lead us in some
demos, which will all work.
Yes, a lot of--
PALI BHAT: You've all got to
cross your fingers for me.
ARIEL BARDIN: We don't
need to cross fingers.
Everything's going to be fine.
PALI BHAT: Yeah.
ARIEL BARDIN: All right.
No crossing fingers.
All right, back to business.
So Sridhar talked about
a few core principles
that we had when
we designed Android
Pay along with our many
partners in the ecosystem.
The first is simplicity,
second is security, and choice.
So let's talk through all these.
And let's focus specifically
on the real world, tap and pay,
and we'll talk
next about in-app.
Simplicity.
We want to unlock our
phone, tap, and be done,
and that should be
a very easy process.
And of course, credit cards
and debit cards need to work.
We need to be able to use them
very easily on our phones.
But we didn't want
to stop there.
When you talk to users, they
do other things at the store
when they actually check out.
Some will use a gift card,
some will use a loyalty card,
and some will use coupons.
So we want to take all
of this information
and pass it during
the tap, make it very,
very simple for users to use it.
We'll start with loyalty.
And Pali will show us a really
cool demo with that machine
that I'm assuming you're
wondering why it's here.
He'll show us how
we can integrate
both a payment and
loyalty information right
within one tap and make it very,
very easy and simple to use.
Let's talk about security.
As Sridhar said, nobody wants
to have problems with their card
number after a purchase
and worry about it.
So we partnered with
the financial networks,
the payments networks,
to adopt tokenization
so that we don't have to
store the actual credit card
information on the
phone, and I'll
talk about that a
little bit in a moment.
The second thing
we do is we look
at over 100 signals
with our own risk engine
before we let a
transaction go through
and when a card is
added to the phone.
So we've got a
software solution,
but we don't stop there,
we also look at hardware.
And as you heard in
the keynote, starting
with the M release
of Android we will
support fingerprint
authentication
as well to really bring the
hardware and the software
together and provide a
great level of security
for our users.
So the third key principle
that Sridhar talked about that
was kind of core to
the way we designed
Android Pay was choice.
In Android, we have a
principal of openness.
We love a lot of innovation.
It's that exciting?
Your phone jumped
out of your lap.
Make sure the credit
card is in it, please.
So where was I?
Yes.
So we like innovation.
We want to have open systems.
Having open systems drives
a lot of innovation,
it's good for users.
Users like choice.
So when you think
about tap and pay,
there has to be hardware
that actually supports it,
and almost all phones today--
all Android phones today--
have the hardware needed
to actually do a tap.
In 2012, we added a layer on
top of that as part of KitKat
called host card emulation.
What host card emulation
did was allow developers
to access that hardware so
that they could build apps
on top of tap and pay,
or they could also
use the hardware
for other use cases,
like opening doors, et cetera.
What we're doing
with Android Pay,
though, is we're introducing
a new layer, an API, which
will allow developers-- approved
developers-- to get access
to the same tokenization
services that we use to power
tap and pay.
So think of this as a new
layer on top of the raw iron.
What this means for users is
that they can use the Android
Pay app to make payments--
set up their cards,
pick which card
they want to use,
all that good
stuff-- or they can
use one of approved partner
apps, bank apps, et cetera.
And Pali will be
showing a demo of how
that'll work in a few minutes.
Now, that's a lot to do.
It's not easy.
And the famous saying
is, it takes a village,
and it certainly takes
a village in this case.
So let's talk
about all the folks
that we're working with
across the payments ecosystem
that Sridhar referenced before.
So first, we're
working with carriers
to make sure that all users
can get access to Android Pay
easily.
We're working with AT&T,
Verizon, and T-Mobile,
so that when you buy
a new Android phone,
it'll come preloaded
with Android Pay.
But we don't stop there.
When you walk into
the store, you
should walk out with Android
Pay set up, ready to go.
So the sales people
in the stores
will be able to
help users set up
their phones with
Android Pay, add
the relevant cards, et cetera.
Now, Android Pay will work
on any carrier's phone that
has KitKat, and there's tens
of millions of these phones,
and more and more every day, as
the babies illustrated earlier.
The second folks we partnered
with are the payment networks.
And the payment networks
helped us with tokenization,
that I mentioned before,
and what tokenization
allows us to do is not store
your credit card number
on the phone, but rather
give it to the networks
and get back a virtual account
number that we can securely
store on the phone.
So that's a critical
part of Android Pay
and how it works, and
this partnership is
extremely important to us.
We're also working with the
leading financial institutions,
so you can securely use your
existing debit and credit
cards along with Android Pay.
And actually, before
I go to the merchants,
we have a bunch of
these folks in the room,
and I have a note that
tells me who's here.
So I'd like to see
a show of hands.
This will be like
a trick question.
I believe we have
USAA in the audience?
All right.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Discover?
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah.
PNC?
[APPLAUSE]
US Bank?
All right.
MasterCard?
[APPLAUSE]
I've seen James earlier.
Navy Federal Credit Union?
Whoo.
[APPLAUSE]
American Express.
I know Nick and
Tony are right here.
[APPLAUSE]
Regents?
Welcome.
Bank of America?
[APPLAUSE]
And Visa.
I've seen Matt here.
[APPLAUSE]
Great.
So really, a big
thanks to these guys
for working closely with us for
months now to get us to this
point.
So we're also partnering
with merchants,
because when you
have your phone you
want to be able
to go into stores
and actually tap
and use the phone.
Sridhar mentioned there are
700,000 locations already.
These are some of the
great partners we have.
So to summarize
the first part, we
really think that now is a time
that mobile payments can take
off, and Android Pay and
Android's scale and being part
of the Android ecosystem
and Android system
is going to be a great
boost for mobile payments.
And with that,
I'd like to invite
Pali to do a couple of fun,
successful, wonderful demos.
PALI BHAT: Awesome.
Yeah.
Regardless of what
Ariel told you,
you can cross your
fingers now so
that everything goes perfectly.
I'm just joking.
This is all going to work great.
So first of all, thank
you all for coming.
It's a packed house here, of
course, with our partners,
and lots of other folks
who are interested in this.
And I'm super excited
to be showing you
Android Pay in action for
the very, very first time.
So, very, very excited.
Can you cut to the
WolfVision, please?
So what you have here
is a payment terminal
from our partners at
Ingenico, and I'm just
going to go ahead and charge
myself for something fun.
A specialty cocktail sounds
just right right now.
So as you can see, they
have a cool Android Pay
logo on the terminal as well.
And I have Android Pay
loaded on this phone,
and so all I have
to do to pay is tap.
And this is the best part.
What we did, as
Sridhar talked about,
is we've integrated this
entire process of Android Pay
with paying right into
the Android platform.
And all I have to do to
make a secure payment
is unlock this device.
OK?
So it's that simple.
So it's secure, but it's simple.
So what I'm going to go ahead
and do is enter my pattern.
Everybody can close
their eyes now.
It's OK, you can watch.
I'm going to change my
pattern right after this demo.
OK?
So now all I have to
do is tap and I'm done.
OK?
That simple.
[APPLAUSE]
And of course you
get a notification
right away on your device
when you make a purchase.
So it's simple and it's secure.
But as Ariel was
talking about, payments
don't usually end with just
paying with your card, right?
You usually use loyalty cards,
or coupons, or gift cards
at the point of sale as well.
And so we wanted to figure out
how we solve for that as well.
I don't know about all of you,
but I, frankly, love rewards,
and I never miss a chance to
use a loyalty card or an offer
to save some money.
And it turns out loyalty
programs are super
popular in the United States.
At last count, there were
3.3 billion loyalty program
memberships in the US.
That's a staggering
29 per household.
29.
So it looks like
there's more than just
me that loves loyalty
cards and rewards.
So we wanted to help
out with Android Pay.
There has been a problem with
all of these loyalty cards,
is that no one
likes-- including me--
no one likes carrying
around a bunch of plastic.
So what we've done is taken all
of this loyalty information,
offer information, built
it into Android Pay
so it just works seamlessly.
So the best way to
show what I mean
is to actually do
another live demo.
This time we're going to make it
a little bit more complicated.
So I'm going to get an assist
from our friends at Coca Cola.
To do that, let me
welcome Michelle,
who's the CIO of Coca Cola
North America, onstage.
Michelle?
MICHELLE ROUTH: Pali.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi everyone.
I'm Michelle Routh, and I'm
the CIO for Coca Cola North
America.
And at Coca Cola we want to
bring our Coca Cola products
to consumers wherever
they want them,
so we've been building
out a network of vending
machines across the nation.
In fact, we have
85,000 vending machines
that are tap and ready today.
In addition, we also
want to make sure
that we reward our
most loyal consumers,
so we have created a loyalty
program called My Coke Rewards,
and we've activated that
program at vending machines
to give you one free Coke for
every 10 products purchased.
And My Coke Rewards has
been a huge success.
In the United States, we have
one out of every six households
are members.
So while tapping and
paying is really easy,
using a plastic My Coke
Rewards credit card
at a vending machine to
redeem or earn loyalty points
has been so cumbersome.
So we're so excited
to be using Android
pay to provide a simplified
user experience for consumers
to purchase products,
and bring the payment
and loyalty together as one.
PALI BHAT: So Michelle,
all this talk of Coke
is making me very thirsty.
MICHELLE ROUTH: Well,
Pali, why don't you
go get yourself a Coke?
PALI BHAT: Apparently
one of Michelle's is
85,000 vending machines is
right here on the stage.
Super convenient, huh?
It's amazing how we
plan all this stuff.
So let's go and buy it.
I already told you guys, right?
I love rewards.
So I want to make sure that my
My Coke Rewards card is already
saved to Android Pay.
So if we can cut to
the WolfVision again?
Let's just do a quick check.
So I'm going to go to
my Android Pay app.
And, sure, there's a My
Coke Rewards card on there,
and it also tells you
that I have 27 points.
I don't know if
you can see this.
So try to zoom in, and it
shows you 27 points there.
That's not quite enough for
actually getting a free Coke.
But at the rate I'm
going, I'm going
to get there very, very soon.
So why don't we go
ahead and actually
try making a purchase at this
Coke vending machine out there.
Michelle?
So if we can cut
to the camera here.
So, Coke vending machine.
It's one of the
85,000 that Michelle
talked about that are enabled
for tap and pay payment.
So what I'm going
to do right now
is try to make an
actual purchase.
So just so you guys all know,
this is a real transaction.
What's going to happen right
now is my payment information
is going to get transferred
to the vending machine.
It's connected to the internet.
It's going to actually
authorize my payment right now.
It's a live transaction.
I'm going to go
ahead, make a payment.
And absolutely amazing,
is that it's actually
passed my loyalty information
as well, My Coke Rewards.
So first time you're watching
a transaction go through
with both loyalty information
and payment information
to this vending machine, doing
an authorization in real time.
If you can focus
on this right now?
So it tells you that
I have 27 points.
It's going to give me
another three points,
and I'm going to be
ready for a free drink.
So this is perfect.
It tells me to select a drink.
I'm going to pick one of my
favorite drinks, the Diet Coke.
Thankfully, there's a
Diet Coke left here.
Perfect.
OK?
Got my Diet Coke.
[APPLAUSE]
So Michelle, care for a drink?
MICHELLE ROUTH:
I would love one.
Coca Cola, please.
PALI BHAT: Yeah.
Perfect.
Being the gentleman that
I am, what I'm going to do
is use my free points
to buy her a drink.
Just don't tell her that.
MICHELLE ROUTH: Well,
Pali we want our consumers
to use their My Coke Rewards
points they've earned.
PALI BHAT: That's awesome.
So let's try this again.
So this time it's
going to be free, OK?
We'll go ahead, pay again.
It's managed to do it.
If you can focus on
this, it's actually
authorizing my payment.
And guess what?
It's asking me if I'm
actually ready to pay for it.
It's actually authorizing
a second purchase, I guess.
Ah.
Here we go.
And I'm 30 points away.
So I'm ready to select a drink.
It just shows you in
real time what I've got.
You said Diet Coke?
MICHELLE ROUTH:
Regular Coke, please.
PALI BHAT: Oh, regular.
Awesome.
[APPLAUSE]
Regular Coke for Michelle.
MICHELLE ROUTH: Well,
thank you, Pali.
That was so easy I
think we should toast.
To Coca Cola and Android Pay.
PALI BHAT: A toast to
Coca Cola and Android Pay.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, Michelle.
That was amazing.
I'm going to leave
my Coke right here.
ARIEL BARDIN: Here,
I'll take it for you.
PALI BHAT: Oh, you're
going to take it from me?
So the cool part about
this was it showed you
how simple, convenient,
secure Android Pay is.
When you're buying
a Coke for Ariel
it's pretty refreshing too.
For him, not me.
ARIEL BARDIN: It's a real Coke.
PALI BHAT: Perfect.
So what I wanted to do
now was-- We already
demonstrated how simple
and secure Android Pay is.
I want to switch
to the last point
that Sridhar and Ariel
talked, which is choice.
We believe it's very important
to enable both consumers
and our partners to be able
to innovate on the Android
platform, and so with
Android Pay, what we've done
is we've built this API that
lets our banking partners add
Android Pay to their own apps.
So consumers have a choice
now of using this Android app
that I just showed you or are
using their favorite banking
app.
So to demonstrate
that, I'm just going
to show you an app from USAA.
So I've got a USAA app,
and I have a USAA card,
and I'm going to try to add
my USAA card to Android Pay.
So the home screen welcomes me.
I can check out my accounts.
I actually have two USAA
cards, one from MasterCard
and one from Visa.
OK.
This time I think I'm not
going to show you my PIN.
This is actually my bank app.
Don't want to bother
changing that.
OK?
So as you can see, I have a
USAA MasterCard, a USAA Visa.
So I'm going to try to add my
USAA MasterCard to Android Pay.
I'm going to touch it.
And guess what?
Right at the bottom
of your screen,
you see a simple
message that says
"Add this card to Android Pay."
I'm going to select "Add card."
It tells me I can use this
everywhere, sounds awesome.
So I'm going to
continue, enter my CVC.
Thank you.
OK?
Just entered my secure code,
and now I'm going to continue,
accept the terms
of service, done.
I've now activated Android
Pay with my USAA MasterCard.
[APPLAUSE]
So that was Android Pay
for in-store purchases.
It's simple.
It's secure.
And we've delivered choice
to both our partners
and of course users.
So with that, I'll
hand over to Ariel,
so he can talk about
in-app purchases.
ARIEL BARDIN: Thank you Pali.
I'll take a break
from drinking Coke.
So we talked about in-store.
I'd like to talk a little
bit about in-app, which is
the second part of Android Pay.
So the same principles
apply, simplicity, security,
and choice, and let's
talk about each of them.
So simplicity.
I'm sure everybody has
tried to buy something
in an app, and type in the
credit card number and address
and all this kind of stuff.
And, you know, my kids can do it
really fast, but I can't do it.
So I want a simple solution that
allows me like with one click
to be able to purchase.
So we have to make it
very simple for users
to enter this
information, but we also
have to make it very
easy for the developers
to actually integrate
into their apps.
So those two were
key focuses for us.
And in our current
payments products,
the apps that are
using our solution
are seeing a 4x
improvement in conversions
by using a very simple flow
which makes a lot of sense.
And all of this comes
together in a simple button
that you could see at the bottom
there, Buy with Android Pay.
So as a user,
that's all you have
to look for, within all
these different apps,
and you know that's going to
be very, very easy to purchase.
From a security perspective,
we take the same key components
of what you saw for tap and
pay-- network tokenization,
partnering with payment networks
to secure the credentials,
we take 100 or more signals, and
we use hardware, starting in M,
to secure the transaction.
So let's talk about choice.
Today, when app developers
use our solutions,
they do custom integrations.
And we thought, how can we bring
the Android scale to really
blow this out and have
many, many additional apps
to use Android Pay.
So we're very
excited to announce
that we've now partnered
with payment processors
to make this very easy.
So what this means
is app developers who
are using Braintree,
Stripe, Vantiv, FirstData,
or CyberSource can
integrate very simply,
and in the case of
Braintree and Stripe,
we've simplified
it to the degree
that it's literally less
than 10 lines of code that
can be copied and
pasted into an app,
and Android Pay just shows up.
Between all these
partners, we hope
we will enable thousands of
apps over the next months
to provide users with
a simple experience.
These are the merchants
that have already signed up
to enable Android
Pay, and we're very
excited to keep working with
them to roll out Android
Pay over the next months.
And I think Pali will
now show us another demo
to keep things entertaining.
PALI BHAT: Awesome.
Thanks Ariel.
So I guess buying
that Coke for Ariel
has made me really hungry.
And I guess I'm going to share
a pizza with him as well.
Sounds good, Ariel?
ARIEL BARDIN: As long as
it's delivered promptly.
PALI BHAT: OK.
So he wants it right away.
So I think the best
way to do that is
to show you one of our partner
apps, which is GrubHub,
and order a pizza.
So let's try that.
So I do want a pick up.
Sounds good.
And it's already
detected that I'm
close to Moscone,
which is perfect.
So I'm going to go ahead
and order something.
Ariel, are you OK with me
being a little picky here?
ARIEL BARDIN: It's
quite all right.
PALI BHAT: So let me try to
order a gluten free pizza,
because I don't
want regular pizza.
So, gluten free pizza.
Looks good.
Well, the first result is
Escape from New York Pizza, five
stars, only half a mile away.
Sounds perfect, so I'm
just going to pick that.
OK.
Let's see if I can get
a gluten free pizza.
Margherita sounds good.
I'm just going to select that.
Add to my order.
OK.
And as soon as I'm
ready to order,
the button Buy with
Android Pay shows up.
Now let's see how easy it
is to buy with Android Pay.
So I'm just going to select
the button and I'm done.
Did everyone notice that?
I just selected Buy with
Android Pay and I was done.
It's that simple.
[APPLAUSE]
So as you can see here, I've
used my MasterCard to pay.
So you see my email address
and my MasterCard here,
and my payment is done.
Android Pay is that simple.
Now, Android Pay can be used
in all kinds of different apps,
and I wanted to show you another
example of an awesome app.
This time it's a shopping app.
The app is Wish.
I think you see it.
So wish.com-- really,
really amazing app,
if you haven't tried it-- and
the cool thing about Wish is it
shows you trending deals and the
deals are personalized for you.
So let me show you
another example.
So there's a bunch
of shoes here.
I don't think I
actually want shoes.
Let's see what else
is trending for me.
Usually it goes along
the top and they show you
different categories.
So they have a category
for Google I/O. Guess
they know where I am today.
So I'm just going to pick
Google I/O. Looks like there's
some really cool
deals on Android toys,
so I'm just going to go
ahead and select that.
It's supposed to be $10, but
it's only going to cost me $1,
and I'm going to expense it.
Don't tell Sridhar that.
So I'm just going to go
ahead and pick a collectible,
and when I hit buy, sure enough,
my Buy with Android Pay button
shows up there.
But this time I actually want
to pick a different card, OK?
So I'm just going
to try and see.
It shows me a UI.
You saw the MasterCard I already
used in the previous purchase.
I'm going to try and
pick a different one,
because I have a
Visa card as well.
I'm going to pick a Visa card,
hit Continue, and that's it.
OK?
I can place my
order and I'm done.
So absolutely
streamlined and awesome.
The one other thing that we've
been doing with Android Pay
is thinking about
how we can make
this experience even better.
We can't have just a one
size fits all experience,
and in some cases you don't
even want to bother, like,
placing your item in the cart.
You just want to
be able to buy it.
So an example of that is a new
experience that we have built,
and I'm going to
demonstrate that.
With all this swag
I'm getting, including
all the stuff I'm collecting
outside, I need a bag,
so I'm going to get that
from the Google Store app.
I'm going to go to
the Google store app.
Sounds like there's a
basic backpack for me.
I'm going to select
the backpack.
Just picked a product, mind
you, and what just happened
was Android Pay shows up
at the bottom, OK, right
over the page.
It shows up at the bottom
in integrated apps.
If I want to see what I'm paying
with, I can just swipe up.
OK?
And I see that I'm playing
with my Discover card here,
and it's being shipped directly
to me at the Google office,
because this is, after
all, a work demo.
Now all I need to do is
swipe to pay, and I'm done.
OK?
Absolutely amazing.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So that's Android Pay.
Simple, secure, and lots
of choice for developers.
Ariel?
ARIEL BARDIN: Thank you.
So I'm sure at least one person
is asking him or herself,
so what happened
to Google Wallet?
Who's?
OK.
I see Nick here.
So we launched Google
Wallet back in 2011,
and you could do
tap and pay with it.
We also introduced a Buy with
Google button afterwards,
as well as a bunch of
other functionality,
like sending your friends
money, which is great.
We're seeing, by the
way, huge adoption there,
it's a 400 percent increase
in users year over year.
You can store balance with us,
so if your friend sends you
some money, you can then keep
that as a balance with Google
and you can use a MasterCard
to purchase anywhere
you want to spend that
money, and all this
was bundled into one app.
So what we'd like to
do with Android Pay,
and what we'll do over
the next couple of months
as we roll out
Android Pay, is we're
going to have one app that
will do the in-store purchases,
tap and pay.
We'll rebrand the button, as
you've seen in these demos.
But to answer the question,
what happened to Google Wallet,
we're going to have
a new Google Wallet
app that will focus
solely on those functions,
meaning I have a debit card,
I want to send money easily
to a friend of mine, my friend
wants to collect that money,
spend it with a debit
card, et cetera.
So all those functions
will be in a new app we're
calling New Google Wallet.
I assume the 'New' will
drop at some point.
And so you'll see
that rolling out
over the next couple of months
with Android Pay rolling out.
So to summarize, we're very
excited about mobile payments.
Google is obviously
investing a lot in this area.
And what's most
exciting is to just see
how we can work together
across the payments ecosystem
to really bring simplicity
to users so that they
can enjoy mobile payments.
And with that I
think we'll wrap up.
Oh, there's more.
We've got to work on our acting.
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY: This is very
much in an experimental section
of the talk.
We're thrilled with Android Pay.
We are thrilled with the
kind of broad based support
that we think it
can get, and we are
very grateful to
all the partners
who've been an integral
part of coming here,
and we think there's a lot
that we can get done together.
But we like
challenging ourselves,
and so we wanted to
ask ourselves, hey,
could we create payment schemes
that didn't even require
you to take the phone out?
And as you can imagine,
this can be useful
in scenarios like
a drive through,
where it's kind of hard to take
the phone to make the payment.
And we were motivated by
situations like this one,
that it's hard-- Sorry.
Let's roll the video, please.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE CUSTOMER: Sorry.
CASHIER 1: Nope, didn't work.
MELANIE: Wait for Mommy.
Hang on.
MALE CUSTOMER: 83, 4.
CASHIER 1: Hit cancel.
CASHIER 2: Here's your change.
MALE CUSTOMER: Sorry.
MELANIE: I like to
pay with Google.
CASHIER 3: OK, Melanie,
you're all set.
MELANIE: Thank you.
What do you say?
CHILD: Thank you.
CASHIER 3: Bye.
[APPLAUSE]
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY: So we
are calling this Hands Free,
and this is-- It's at an
early prototype stage,
so we've been working with
a few of our partners,
like McDonald's and Papa John's,
to field-test these ideas out
in the real world.
And here to tell us what Hands
Free can do to the more than
27-plus million customers that
McDonald's serves each day is
Atif, the Chief Digital
Officer of McDonald's.
Welcome Atif.
[APPLAUSE]
ATIF RAFIQ: Thank you very much.
Hi, everybody.
It's great to be here,
and thanks to the Google
team for this opportunity to
participate in a really, really
exciting new innovation.
My name is Atif Rafiq, and
I'm the Chief Digital Officer
for McDonald's.
I'm going to spend the few
minutes that I have here
with you walking
through why we're
so excited about the
potential for Hands Free,
and why it fits so naturally
into where McDonald's is headed
as a company.
So let me start by giving a
little bit of background around
what digital means
to McDonald's.
A lot of folks associate
McDonald's with convenience,
and that is something
we want to perpetuate
for a long, long time.
Now, we believe that the
definition of convenience
is changing, fueled by
technologies like mobile,
and we think it's time to
introduce an entirely new level
of convenience
for how people get
their food on an everyday
basis, and that's
what our focus is as a company.
We're a provider
of every day food.
So the possibilities for
McDonald's to use digital
as a way to add convenience
are really endless.
We invented the drive-through.
I believe that mobile
will allow us to reinvent
that drive-through experience.
We're getting into the game
on delivery for mobile.
And imagine being able to
come into the restaurant
and skipping the line, taking
a seat, and having your food
brought directly to you.
That is something
we're already trying,
and mobile is going to be
an important ingredient
to that experience as well.
Now, using McDonald's may seem
like a very simple experience,
and in fact it is, but
there's a lot happening there
when you unpack the
customer journey,
and one of the key steps in
the customer journey is paying.
So behind me what you can see is
Hands Free in action at a local
McDonald's.
We couldn't bring the restaurant
into the Moscone Center.
They weren't cool with that
like the Coca Cola machine,
so we had to package it
up in the form of a video.
But as you can see, it's
really very, very simple.
So how cool would it be to step
into a McDonald's and simply
say, I'm here to
pay with Google.
I think that'd be
really, really neat.
So what you're going to be
able to do is no longer forage
through your pocket or your
bag to pay at McDonald's.
You simply arrive, convey
your order to the crew person,
let them know that you
want to pay with Google,
and Hands Free takes
care of the rest.
The app helps us
verify that it's you,
and we've integrated
our systems.
So once Hands Free securely
charges your account,
we give you your food
and you're on your way.
It's really just that simple.
So to quickly summarize,
we're big believers
in the future of
frictionless commerce.
We think that's coming to
the offline world at a very
rapid pace, and we intend to use
that as an opportunity to add
an entirely new level
to our experience.
And it's for this reason
that we're really, really
excited to team up with
Google on Hands Free.
Suffice it to say we're really
excited to be a launch partner,
and we're ready to co-create a
world that's just so radically
simpler and more convenient
around how you get
your food on an everyday basis.
So having said that, let me
hand it to back to Sridhar.
[APPLAUSE]
SRIDHAR RAMASWAMY: You're
going to be rolling up
trials of Hands Free in select
locations in the Bay Area.
If you'd like to be a
part of it, go to this URL
and sign up with your email.
And it's time to conclude.
This is been a long journey,
but as I said earlier,
we are incredibly excited
by what is ahead of us.
We think the situation with
consumers, the availability
of devices that are
capable of making
mobile payments, the
changes that are happening
on the merchant
side, and of course,
the willingness of
the payments industry
to be great partners in this
change that is happening,
is what I think will
make a big difference
to consumers, and not only
create the experiences that we
saw today, but many more amazing
ones that we have hinted at.
For example, in the
demos that Pali showed,
with reward cards and
loyalty cards and so on.
So I'm very excited
by the possibility.
I'm very thankful to all of you
for being such great partners
in all of this.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]